former Georgian President Mikheil
Saakashvili is preparing to make a
political comeback as deputy prime
minister to Ukraine Saakashvili says
president Vladimir's olanski has asked
him to drive economic and political
reforms in Ukraine Parliament must now
approve his candidacy it would be
Saakashvili second stint in Ukrainian
politics he served as governor of the
country's Odessa region in 2015 but quit
after falling out with Ukraine's then
prayer leader Petro poroshenko
Saakashvili cited corruption amongst
officials as his reason for stepping
down and in an exclusive interview GW
asked me Hal Saakashvili how he plans to
succeed where he had once failed mr.
sacker sir how did you get the
opportunity Prime Minister did it come
from president Olinsky it came from the
president the landscape we see with whom
I have very good contacts it came from
prime minister schmegle and with
specific mandate to help to strengthen
the government's capacity to the reforms
because reforms is what it crane needs
the most special in this after hard
times four years ago you're assigned as
a governor for Ukraine Odessa region you
made this decision because in you it was
impossible to fight corruption among
officials what makes you believe that it
will be different this time because
poroshenko was chief and the lansky is
definitely against this that's for sure
we can argue about different aspects of
his polish but I had no doubt about it
that he has correct direction
he is absolutely sincere in his desire
to tackle the old system but right now
either old yo either he will drain the
swamp or the old system which will
swallow him and I don't want to for
Ukrainians to lose his hope their hope
because the last is still very much
connected with their hope and that's why
they gave him this mandate so I really
want to help this young team I want to
help the president and I think Ukraine
is approaching very critical period and
it's really a huge challenge right now
and it's the biggest largest country in
Europe we cannot allow this country to
collapse and this is this is this is a
real challenge because you know if
Ukraine is called economy collapses as
it is project
considering what are the separatist
forces what are these the decibel izing
impulses from Russia we are facing with
we are faced with very dangerous attack
situation not only for us here but for
the entire into European continent and
that's why Ukraine needs very special
approach attitude and I want to be in
charge of president mandate me if I'm
confirmed to conduct too big charge of
talks with the IMF and other
international institutions I have huge
experience of doing that and to do also
to tackle the issue of of deregulation
to decrease and change this but and mmm
well get rid of opportunities for
corruption when I was president of
Georgia Georgia progress from hundred
twenty seven places in terms of Ease of
Doing Business to number eight in the
world I can deliver the same thing for
Ukraine
I want Ukraine to be top among the best
destinations to invest and to the
business with and that would be my
mandate and goal
if you month ago you you've won that
Ukraine might fall apart into five
pieces no Ukraine that's certainly the
dream of Philemon Putin to make to have
not won Ukraine but thoroughly cranes
and but with you but and you know unless
Ukraine reforms and tackle corruption
and also cracks down on separatists in
the way of rule of law we we are facing
the risk let's face it but I think with
proper strong policy we can definitely
avoid avoid the night mercenary not only
for Ukrainians for us here for the
entire world that's the last thing we
want to see and that we we certainly are
not going to allow it happened but there
we know one guy his name's not even
Putin who certainly not only dreams
about it he tax cells he talks about it
he does it if he is allowed to do it to
accomplish this goal he promised the
peace and on bus your relations is
Russia as as it known have been strained
since your presidents in Georgia how can
you support
student who is ready to make incisions
Thomas de Crillon well I I'm also for
peace with Russia and until now I've
supported every step at over in terms of
peaceful presence the last year because
I think that's what the Ukrainian people
and any nation would want in the world
but it takes tango - it takes - to the
dance tango we need a partner in that
talks and unfortunately we are not
getting the same attitude from the
Russians look the fact that president
Alaska nominated me for this very high
political position the fact that it has
been followed by outburst of very dirty
/ hysterical propaganda on Russian
official media is saying that slansky
knew that it would happen but he still
took the risk which means that he feels
that his head of independent state that
stakes its own independent decision it's
a bad news for anyone who thought that
Ukraine would be less independent and
more subservient to anyone and so yeah
that's also big political message to the
Ukrainian people onto the outside that
Ukraine is feels that they should take
their their own free decisions way in
contact with during his election
campaign what did you talk about did he
promise you any high positions in the
government in case of his victory I
campaigned for the landscape when I was
exiled by previous president poroshenko
I met lots of Ukrainian grace all around
the Europe station in Poland thousands
of them and I I called on them to call
for to watch for Zaleski I never asked
anything in exchange when I in
parliamentary campaign I removed my
party from the list and who asked our
waters to endorse I endorsed the rescue
for our waters to vote for him I never
asked for anything ID in fact I have I'm
not really known him
I met him later and we had the instant
meeting of minds and I'm relatively I'm
directly fascinated by this very
interesting I cannot call him a
politician he certainly is not a
politician but he's a very good
president and he has chance to be the
best president in history of Ukraine if
he delivers on those reforms and I am
willing to help him in delivering
because then in speeding them up because
that's in everybody's interests
did you realize what it will be in the
Ukraine after kovat 19 Ukraine is going
to have faced very difficult challenges
our economy is going to be to collapse
by more than 78 percent of GDP we are
going to get several millions of extra
unemployed not least the people who came
back from Europe
Ukrainian so-called heirs Arabic Chinese
who are making their money in Europe and
Ukraine is not in good shape right now
to cope with those challenges that's why
we need urgent changes we need to crack
down on corruption we need to change the
entire system that has existed here for
survived Soviet Union and existed in
Ukraine for the last 40 years our goal
is to win the entire philosophy of
administration here and without that
there is no long-term success or even
survival because this crisis is a huge
challenge but it's also an opportunity
to reform it's an our opportunity to
change thank you very much for more on
this story let's cross over to DW
correspondent Nick Conley in cave Nick
how does an exiled former Georgian
president end up becoming the Deputy
Prime Minister in Ukraine well this has
got to be a one-off hasn't it I mean
just imagine a former Portuguese say
president becoming a senior minister or
a vice prime minister in angular
Merkel's government for instance is just
unthinkable this seems like a story from
the 18th century where European
countries were bringing in monarchs from
other countries to rule them but he is
really a kind of a maverick an unusual
guy for an unusual time he is no
stranger to Ukraine he studied here back
in the 80s when his home country of
Georgia and Ukraine were in the same
country in the Soviet Union he made
friends with Petro poroshenko at
university he went on to become
president as did he he really built a
reputation for himself as a disrupter as
a real liberalizing someone who was
willing to make enemies in the in the
path of really shaking up that
post-soviet system for instance when
faced with a corrupt police force he
just fired everyone and hired newbies
whose only real qualification for lots
the time was just having nothing to do
with the previous regime in the previous
police so someone with all of enemies
but also who has really built a brand
around that kind of
compromising reforms something that lots
people here in Ukraine are yearning for
concerned that Ukraine is really just
muddling through and not living up to
its full potential
so this is someone who also as we
mentioned before has fallen out with his
bosses here in Ukraine before Petro
poroshenko stripped him of his passport
he broke over the border to come back in
an extraordinary scenes then he was
running over the rooftops behind me so
this is someone who really thrives in a
crisis it's so it's safe to say that
he's not your standard politician make
why bring him into the game now I think
there's no coincidence that this is
happening now at a time of extraordinary
stress through covert nineteen millions
of Ukrainians lost their jobs most have
savings that will only last them a month
or so those are the forecasts and the
government simply just doesn't have the
cash to pay their wages as is happening
in Western European countries say added
to that the borders are shot millions of
Ukrainians work in Western Europe and
send money back their families they
mostly lots of them have returned about
two million our estimates have returned
and they can't get back to work will
those jobs be there for them to get when
their borders reopen we don't know
certain extraordinary stress so
president Olinsky I think he's he's real
gamble now is that given he can't give
people cash he can't promise them
support now he has to sell them a dream
of an improved Ukraine and real real
deep structural change and that is
what's actually brings with his promise
of reforms and his track record back in
Georgia interesting times Nick Connolly
in cave thanks for joining us